we're living through the most political
moment in American history but stories
like the one you just saw transcend
politics we don't know who anyone in
that tape voted for but we know exactly
how they felt as human beings afraid and
alone and that's what happens when the
government ceases
conducting its most basic Duty which is
to protect its citizens and they won't
they won't protect you they've said that
out loud and everybody knows it again no
matter who they voted for
and so increasingly Americans are having
to defend themselves and once again
anyone who tells you can't defend
yourself
is your enemy
so here's an example that is amazing and
we think you'll agree that it is in
Tampa last month a woman called nishali
Alma was working out in her her
apartment complex as Jim because she's a
kind person she let in a man who was
trying to open the door that man then
attempted to rape her you're seeing the
footage on your screen right now and the
Shelley almond did not have a gun she
was in a gym
but she's extraordinarily tough and she
was able to fight off the man who was
trying to rape her his name is Xavier
Thomas Jones Thomas Jones was later
arrested after he tried to rape another
woman in the apartment complex
the resilience and the strength you see
in that video is so inspiring and so
perfectly capture is the best part of
America that we wanted to speak to
Natalie Alma tonight and she was
gracious enough to agree she joins us
now Michelle thank you so much for
coming on anyone who watches that video
and again it's not a political point but
just has to stand back in awe at your
ferocity what how did you summon this so
this man is bigger than you and he's
totally determined to hurt you and you
literally fought him off what what were
you thinking
um in my head you know whenever it was
happening
uh I wasn't really fearful at all in my
head it was just
wait I gotta fight him I gotta do
something you know and he was equal to
me he wasn't bigger than me he wasn't
anything more than my size and I kind of
took that to my advantage to my own head
and I fought him
what's there's a moment in the tape I've
watched like four times it's so
interesting he comes towards you and he
hasn't even grabbed you yet and you
determined this guy is gonna hurt me
he's an enemy you don't lie to yourself
you just immediately go after him why
and a lot of people don't do that they
lie to themselves why were you able to
know exactly what this man's intention
was
right
um is because my mom always told me
don't let anybody ever approach you or
touch you if you don't know them and as
soon as he approached me I knew I had to
push him off or do something yeah well
you certainly did do something and the
guy just yeah and like you were so
ferocious with him that he just finally
gave up
yeah
after a little bit of resting on the
ground I yanked out his beard hairs and
he eventually gave out
so what I mean this is the scene I think
that that a lot of people women
particularly fear you're alone in the
gym at night and some rapist comes in
and tries to literally rape you what
advice having lived through it would you
give people watching
um you know like I said some people
forget their key fob and they do let
people in
um for their kindness their hearts but
always be cautious always watch your
back and if you're ever in that
situation fight back
amen amen fight back that is it's just
wonderful but thank you for what you did
and congratulations on Thanksgiving
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight